there's a great new study from the
University of Oxford it's no Wharton I
know but let's give it a chance and the
study is about fake news in the United
States and what it did was look at the
three months leading up to Trump State
of the Union address which was last week
and what the study found was that on
Facebook extreme hard right
conservatives shared more fake news
stories than all other political groups
combined okay on Twitter Trump
supporters consumed the most fake news
and the Twitter numbers are actually
scary there were a whole group of fake
news sites that the researchers had on a
watch list Trump supporters on Twitter
shared articles from 95% of the fake
news sites that were on the watch list
for this research to be clear we're
talking about actual fake news and junk
news right I'm not talking about calling
articles you disagree with fake news
which is what Donald Trump likes to do
I'm talking about actual fake news and
the results are actually not that
surprising there are previous studies
about online misinformation and
disinformation and it's overwhelmingly
conservatives that fall for this garbage
and share it on the Internet in 2011
there was a good study done remember
when chain emails were a thing chain
emails would go around think this
horrible things going on forward this to
20 people or whatever and the study
looked at chain emails political chain
emails from 2007 to 2011 and of the 79
bogus political chain emails that
circulated in those four years to two
significant degrees four were targeting
Republicans and almost all of them were
targeting Democrats or Obama or Hillary
or immigration fear-mongering about
immigrants that type of thing
overwhelmingly right-wing conspiracy
theories another study estimated that 80
percent of political chain emails from
the ten year period ending in 2011 were
right-wing misinformation so the date is
pretty clear but the more interesting
question for us is why right why is it
that it's conservatives
disproportionately sharing consuming and
believing fake news is it they're just
dumb right that seems like a simple of
an explanation is it well the Liberals
are the dumb ones because they've not
figured out how to use these techniques
to their advantage
I think a major factor is that the right
has successfully framed the idea that
the media won't tell you the truth right
and once you believe we're on the right
or conservatives we're not going to get
the truth from the media once you
believe that you're primed number one to
just be super skeptical of anything you
hear in the media to an irrational
degree we should all have a healthy
skepticism about what we are told by
corporate media by all media including
this program but when you carry that
around to such an irrational degree
you'll start believing that everything
you're getting from the meat the media
is lies and thus when some seemingly
absurd harebrained conspiracy theory
crops up you're more open to those ideas
because you already have sort of
integrated the corporate media narrative
the mainstream media narrative as
possibly false or deceptive a normal
person understands okay yeah
the media has biases but I get the
difference between reporting an opinion
and I can evaluate for myself what types
of claims in the media are accurate in
which I should be skeptical of when you
hear something totally outrageous like I
don't know Obama's Indonesian Muslim
with a fake birth certificate or
whatever you'll be highly skeptical
because you will already have developed
a sort of fine-tuned filter for media
messages if your context is just media
tells us straight-up lies
you are way more likely to believe that
maybe Obama is a shape-shifting alien or
Hillary is minutes away from being
arrested and put in an orange jumpsuit
when you read it on some fake news trash
site or whatever this is a way that the
right has been co-opted and primed to
believe this stuff and Trump's actually
making it worse you know because Trump
now has expanded the use of fake news
way beyond what it actually
intended to mean and now you've got
people on the right who think actual
news agencies are so-called fake news
and it only further primes them to
accept this type of garbage C shared on
social media maybe some of it has to do
with the fact that liberals tend to be
better educated not to say that there
aren't intelligent people on the right
of course but I'd have to imagine that
progressives do have better critical
thinking and media literacy skills it
also comes down to what new sources
liberals are going to maybe yes network
television or its NPR or its independent
shows like us whereas if you look at the
right-wing maybe the older audience is
going to Fox News cable networks but
many of the younger generation people
are going right bar yes or these like
fringe website well the study looked at
that as well the study actually found
that algorithms that determine what you
see on social networks are so bolstering
echo chambers that there's often almost
no overlap like if you imagine a Venn
diagram of news sources for
conservatives and news sources for
liberals you would think that there
would be some significant level of
overlap because there are sort of
baseline news reporting agencies The
Associated Press or Reuters or whatever
the study found that there's almost no
overlap and that's part of the major
polarization that's taking place and
this is something I've spoken about
extensively before the echo chambers and
the filter bubbles that are social
networks in one way are very effective
in that they are calibrated for high
engagement engagement meaning sharing
and commenting and sending to your
friends but at the same time what you're
most likely to share is stuff that fits
into your existing worldview and thus
people are spending time on social
networks where they are finding only a
self manifesting narrative that further
ingrains them in their beliefs and there
has been that paradigm shift because
decades ago you only had three networks
yeah on television that was your source
of news maybe you read a paper you're
over there sharing you're engaging in
social media it's a lot different now
yeah not only that but you've also got
you know the growth of am talk radio
you've got cable news as opposed to just
over-the-air news internet so many other
other areas it's bad it's really bad out
there and we
that it is indeed the right that is
disproportionally buying into actual
fake news not Trump's definition of the
term the actual definition of the term
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
re d di t quick break back after this if
you've been hearing about Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency and you want to get
involved maybe buy a little but you just
don't know how
coin base is for you coin base is the
world's most used way to buy sell and
use Bitcoin aetherium light coin and
Bitcoin cash if you sign up through
david pakman.com slash coin base and buy
or transfer $100 worth of bitcoin you'll
get a $10 bonus and so will we
so you'll be supporting the David Pakman
show sign up today at david pakman.com
slash coin base